Ever wondered what he was thinking
or maybe you've always wanted to express your feelings without saying a word.
What if you could read someone's mind and they could read yours?
Would there be no secrets left?
Would mind control become possible to and how could you keep your privacy if
everyone knew what was on your mind,
this is what if and here's what would happen if brain to brain communication was
possible.
Let's be honest.
The way we communicate is pretty slow.
It takes time.
From the moment that thought comes to your mind,
to the moment you say it to someone even longer with your two finger typing,
our brain is much faster than that.
On average,
you have 50,000 thoughts a day.
That's 35 thoughts per minute.
You can't type all of them,
nor can you put them into words.
Imagine how fast we could exchange information if we can just transmit our
thoughts directly to another brain.
Once we started communicating through thought,
we'd turn into a giant mind melding network.
Humanity would become much more innovative.
Since the more people shared their ideas,
the more other people would be able to improve upon them.
This would boost technology to a level we can't yet imagine.
Sharing our knowledge through thoughts would also make us more coordinated.
This would not only benefit all military structures,
but also emergency services.
You'd be able to think nine one one instead of calling them very handy.
If your phone's dead,
we'd be learning much faster and easier instead of verbally explaining a
difficult concept.
Your teacher could give you a better representation of it through thought and
don't forget things with artificial intelligence.
If your car had a mind of its own,
you'd be able to control it with your mind.
Same goes for your phone,
computer,
robot,
pet,
anything that might have an AI while controlling things.
Sounds awesome.
What if this led to controlling people's minds?
They might sound interesting,
but it wouldn't seem that great if you the one being controlled.
Luckily,
the way it would work,
work would be that just like we can choose what to say,
we'd be able to choose what thoughts to share with others.
No one would read your thoughts unless you let them.
That's a relief,
isn't it?
This new era of mind reading would be pretty silent without the need to push air
through our lungs and into our voice box.
We might eventually for debt language and the sound of it,
but at least you'd never struggled to tell your crush exactly how you felt about
them.
You'd literally show them your feelings.
We don't know much about our bundle of neurons.
We don't fully understand why we sleep or how our consciousness marks,
but we do know how to read our brain.
Yep,
you heard it right.
Our brain fires neurons that receive transmit and process information through
electrical and chemical signals,
and we can read those signals.
With the help of this method
or Eeg,
what's more,
we can now transmit information from one brain to another.
We have a method for that.
Transcranial magnetic stimulation or tms.
This stimulation sends electrical current to the receivers brain activating a
small area of it,
the same one that was active in the senders brain.
That might not exactly be the telepathy from science fiction,
but that's what talking through thought would look like in real life and we
don't always talk.
We use devices to communicate with each other.
Eventually we just switched to faster technologies.
The ones that would let you send your thoughts,
the way you send your emails.
Do you think you'll still be around to use EEG and tms is instead of your mobile
phone?